madison kenyon is a college track
athlete who also competed against
biological males she joins me now to
share her story along with her attorney
kristen wagoner thank you both for being
with us i should say
that while leah thomas hasn't had gender
affirming surgery he did have a year's
worth of i believe hormonal treatment
which is what the ncaa requires in many
situations but madison it doesn't change
the biological fact that he's a man he
went through puberty as a man he has
muscle
structure and and and everything through
22 years of his life as a man and
madison you've competed against this
exact situation in track you've competed
against transgender athletes
yeah i think i missed um your question
because it glitched do you mind asking
it again
yeah sure would you tell us tell all of
us watching right now what is it like to
go into a competition against a
transgender athlete when you know
the outcome ahead of time
yeah it's extremely deflating i've
experienced it five times and each time
i lost to a biological male and the fact
that that's still happening that women
are still losing to biological males in
their own sport shows why we need more
female athletes to speak up about this
and so i just kind of want to say to the
female athletes in pennsylvania don't
let anyone silence you speak up tell the
ncaa your athletic directors and your
coaches that you want fair competition
because doing this is nowhere near as
scary as it seems and the amount of
support is overwhelming
madison i'm just curious you ran track
right what was your what was your event
so i did the 3k and indoor track in the
and i also ran cross country
and then when did you start running when
did you start competing in track how old
were you i think you asked me what event
i did but again it glitched um i ran
i'm sorry you're gonna have to ask the
question i don't know what you asked
i'll ask you one more time we'll see if
we can work through this glitch um how
how old were you when you started
training for competition and track
oh i started
cross country in middle school and
track in high school so
around okay so
so you started training at the age of 14
and within a matter of i would assume a
couple of months a biological male
stepped in and beat you after all of
your years of training
yeah so my first uh collegiate race i
raced against a biological male and they
beat me
it's somebody's to your point janet
evans you know missy franklin katie
ledecky somebody has to step up and say
this is not right this is not right uh
mrs wagner i'd love to get you in on
this you know the i mentioned what the
ncaa rules are about hormonal treatment
and you know different states at the
high school level have different laws
what should the laws be when it comes to
this
they're simple the law should be that
biological women compete against
biological women and the ncaa policy
doesn't require the university of
pennsylvania to deny a fair playing
field to women it doesn't require that
at all in fact what it's doing is
prioritizing activists over women
athletes and by denying them a fair
playing field they're refusing again to
recognize legitimate biological
distinctions and that hurts women and
girls the most
you know and i think many are guided by
empathy but they're prioritizing
empathizing with one individual over the
hundreds the thousands of madisons out
there that have trained their entire
life it's very selective in where you
apply your empathy and by the way it's
the end of women's sports madison and
kirsten thank you both for jumping on
with us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else